hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we're going
to be talking through the headlines with
the author and journalist ella whelan
and author and historian at oxford
university peter francapan so a very
good evening to both of you nice to see
you
so let's take a look at what's making
those front pages and the sunday
telegraph
talks vouchers for vaccines as it
analyzes the government's plans to
incentivize
covid19 vaccinations kebabs
for jabs reads the front of the sunday
people as it also
looks at vaccine rewards the saudi times
reports that rishi sunak has urged the
prime minister to lift travel
restrictions with the headline
dump travel rules to save holidays
the observer leads with warnings from
kia stalma's aides who say the labour
party has lost
touch with target voters
carrie and boris johnson's baby joy is
the focus
of the sun on sunday's front page
and boris's baby news also makes the
main story of the sunday express which
reads
incredibly blessed well the daily star
sunday's headline about the prime
minister reads so
that's what he's been doing in the
lockdown
i don't know what they mean by that
let's bring in then ella whelan and
peter francopan
to go through those front pages and and
ella let's start with the sunday express
which is one of the papers that's led
with the news today
that carrie johnson um is pregnant um
incredibly blessed it is a a line that
she used when she broke the news on
instagram today wasn't it
yes and isn't it a funny thing breaking
the news on
instagram it's incredibly such a modern
um way to do it perhaps good because
it's tapping into a younger generation
but i still think this kind of
not quite that she's like a first lady
but the sort of formal news like this
instagram seems like a weird format to
do it but anyway here we are and
news of a new baby is always a lovely
thing and should be celebrated
i quite like the headlines that are
joking about the fact that they got
between the sheets throughout lockdown
because it makes boris johnson seem
uh you know a little bit more normal i
think
they said there has been a sort of
proselytization of him as having to be
this perfect
sort of saint-like figure which he often
falls short of
throughout and that politicians are sort
of a little bit abnormal but if this is
you know doing what most couples have
been doing there's not much else to do
over the last
16 months then uh congratulations to
them and
she's named it a rainbow baby and which
is in some other
bits of the paper which is a term that
people use when they
uh have a positive pregnancy test and
the hopes of a baby coming after
loss or death and so that's a really
nice thing well that's right and in fact
peter if we look inside the sun on
sunday they've led on the story on their
front page but inside as well they've
got a double page spread here that
you've picked out saying
our rainbow um it's a term i hadn't
heard before actually but
she has been very open about the fact
that she did have a miscarriage earlier
this year and said that she deliberately
wanted to share that information
to give some kind of comfort to other
people who might be going through the
same thing
well it's a hugely traumatic experience
for any couple
and for any would-be mother to to
experience and i think it's it's
absolutely right
quite a few of the newspapers tomorrow
making the point that it's it's the last
real
taboo to be able to talk about that kind
of loss
and what it means physically emotionally
and the pressure that it puts and so i
think it's rather beautiful to call it
sort of a carriage say that she's
incredibly blessed i mean as ella says
it's a very modern way
of uh announcing it but i suppose number
10 has also got an eye
on trying to get the communications
right and by offering a story to one of
the newspapers
it puts him in pole position and what
what clearly i guess number ten is
trying to do
is to draw a line on the one hand
between um the couple's private life
and the fact that we're now gonna have a
prime minister in office with
uh two children under the age of two and
um i think anybody who's
had small children or been in a room
with small children knows that
concentrating on the day job is quite
difficult when you
live above where you work so um you know
wishing them all the best is obviously
great news
and uh you know lift a couple lift the
country too you know wonderful
in fact what ella says about everyone's
been doing it in fact funnily enough
it's sort of
slightly counterintuitive in fact
there's been a big uh not a baby boom
there's been a baby bust because of
covered in the in the developed rich
world
lots of people have been putting off
having children um and they haven't been
the
same frequency of one night stands for
very obvious reasons to sometimes lead
to unintended
consequences and so in fact boris is
going against the grain in this one
because
in fact there's going to be quite a
small school year that the new one will
go into
uh because of uh people's sexual
practices as we've been more locked down
something i didn't expect to be talking
about this evening but but there you go
interesting stuff
some of us have been working from home
actually during lockdown
anyway let's let's move on to the sunday
times front page story shall we and
they are focusing on the chancellor
rishi sunak
apparently according to the sunday times
putting pressure on
um to try and lift travel restrictions
as there is a review coming up later
this week on thursday i think ella
and he wants a lot of the restrictions
dumped for the sake of the economy i
think it's his argument isn't it
yes so um he's apparently written to
boris johnson and
in the uh in the sort of way in which
boris has had
i don't know if you can quite put a
devlin an angel on his shoulder
depending on your view of lockdown
restrictions continuing
there certainly has been conflicting
views being whispered in his ear and
whether to go hard
on continuing lockdown measures whether
to come off and take his foot off the
pedal and
get back to or get forward to a kind of
new normal and richie sooneck has been
one of those quite strident voices for a
while now suggesting that
the cost to the economy and the cost to
people's
wages to their jobs to um the you know
wider scope of um the employment market
is
is too much to bear uh moving forward
with with
more lockdown restrictions and a key
part of that is obviously travel what
risky student is picking up on here is
not just the fact that
the tourism industry has taken a hit
it's not just the fact that
uh you know to the travel industry as we
saw in previous lockdowns has um
come out kind of kicking and screaming
wanting to get some kind of business
going back again
but it's a more general sense in which
actually going on holiday isn't just
about having a jolly it's also about
people traveling
people bringing income back in to the
country and so you know it's a fair
i'm it's a fair position to have and the
crucial thing is when
we are getting to a point at which
vaccination levels
are rising are doing very well there's a
very been a very positive take-up of the
vaccine in this country
uh it's there's the reasons to remain
locked down and the reasons to remain in
a kind of restrictive setting
lessen as the vaccine becomes the
bacterium rollout becomes more
successful
so a little bit of positivity like this
i think is to be welcomed and yet there
will be some no doubt some in government
as well peter who
are more cautious aren't they they worry
about losing that vaccine advantage if
you can call it that
by allowing people to come into the
country potentially bringing other
variants with them
well i think that that's clearly the big
debate for the on the science side of
how do we
balance um new variations picking up
either in europe or beyond
and trying to work that that all out and
and i think that the jury is out i mean
it's been quite a good 10 days of
falling cases but the real worry is is
is
mutations of concern that that's that
provide
a much bigger challenge for us to deal
with as we go into the winter months
but i mean it's i suppose interesting
about this story that both the sunday
times
and the sun take and of course they're
stable mates as newspapers
but it's quite astute positioning from
richie sunic i suppose it's a bit like
cara johnson announcing on instagram uh
i presume the chance i didn't have to
write boris a letter that he told
everybody about he could
he could have nobled him in the
corridors of number 10 or number 11 down
east street so some of this i suppose
is about the chancellor positioning
himself to be saying
um look i'm i'm on the side of those
wanting to have a more liberal approach
uh even though he's been quite hawkish
through the process but you know this
week british airways announced it lost
two billion pounds
airlines are really expensive to keep on
the ground and
getting back up in the air is a real
headache so there's got to be something
that
that starts to get the economy going and
i think opening those borders
is a key part of that and do you think
also peter you say that
he's positioning himself on one side of
the party if you like but do you think
he's also trying to send out a popular
message to people lots of people like
going on holiday after all
i think i mean he's had he's had a good
good pandemic rishi no doubt about that
he's
he's presentable he's eloquent uh he's
been in front of the guns when he's
needed to be
and some of the other schemes in the
papers that we'll talk about a bit later
is about
what kind of incentives could be given
to encourage people to get vaccinated so
you know i think
he's he's very competent but there's no
question i think that
while we all have the impression that a
lot of government is arguing with each
other
having a sort of racing line that you
stick to and that you are
being reasonable about is it's quite
good to show that your credible
future leader as i think asuna has done
quite well
and let's talk about those incentives
ella because it makes the front page of
the observer elsewhere in the papers as
well
and the news that uh various incentives
will be offered
they look like they're targeting young
people um to try to encourage them to
get vaccinated it looks like we may have
had
talk of sticks talk of people being
stopped from doing
things if they weren't double vaccinated
and now it looks like we're getting
carrots
is that right yeah yeah something like
that kind of a mix of a stick and a
carrot
i mean we remembered the eat out to help
out in the government scheme
um to incentivize people to get out it's
a similar thing going on here with young
people where
uh uber and bolt and delivery and lots
of other companies that predominantly
18 to 25 year olds use quite frequently
cabs and takeaways and that kind of
thing could be involved in a government
scheme
um to get you know the the situation at
the moment is that
about 60 um of young people of that age
bracket have had at least one jab but to
make sure that they continue
and finish um their jab program and get
the second one
there could be this suggestion of of
carrots
and you know it's a tricky one isn't it
because i think that the
the you know you don't want to go down
the route of france
where you have essentially vaccine
passports uh now being instituted
at pretty much in any kind of fun public
space whether it be a cafe a bar or you
know
a concert um but the the
sort of uh carrot angle the trying to
incentivize things
um only i think should be rolled out if
there's a real downturn and actually
what we've seen is among young people
whether it's them queuing outside of
twickenham
whether it's actually levels of young
people volunteering as vaccinators i've
been doing a few shifts as a vaccinator
and it's always full of
young people even in care roles or
actually sticking needles in people's
arms
there's been quite a positive um
response to it and so maybe building on
that positive response perhaps with a
few delivery vouchers but more actually
um a kind of political message that says
to continue this societal good this
social project of uh getting out this
virus together that we have in the shape
of the vaccine programme
perhaps could we could do with that too
well yes that's right and we've
we've learned today that possible plans
that were certainly floated peter about
telling students they had to have two
jabs if they were going to be able to
stay in a hall of residence or attend
lectures even have been abandoned that
doesn't seem to be happening
so does it feel like incentives is the
way the government is likely to go from
here on in
but you both sound like you've been
living in a different household to me
over lockdown the idea that anyone's
going to want to eat a carrot
rather than i think the the it's the
kebabs for jabs
young people are incredibly smart and
they're incredibly um
sophisticated in the in the way in which
they share information and share
information quickly
and i think that um as some of the
stories that are pointing out in the
star and other and other places
um 60 of of 18 to 25 year olds
have had one jab and so it seems that if
you're part of the 40 percent
you might as well stick around and wait
and get a bit of freebies and free kit
to come round and presume that'll happen
with the second jab too so
the problem about offering incentives is
that the people who've already had their
their shop their job who've been good
citizens then don't get their
frappuccinos or their pizzas or their
kebabs or whatever it might be
so so calibrating how that works and why
it's 18 to 25 and not up to 30. you know
i feel
bad myself that i didn't stick around
and wait i mean some countries in russia
to get a job you can enter a lottery to
win a snowmobile
so um you know maybe some kebabs
are too low so other countries are doing
in a kind of lottery system that if you
uh need to be persuaded put your name in
and we'll pull out a few lucky winners
the problem is if you make small
incentives for people then of course the
market will take
take hold itself and young people who
communicate faster and quicker than
people my age
will work out how to play the system to
to get the best possible reward quite
rightly
i think there are a lot of students who
would pick the kebab over the snowmobile
in the deer any day
although who knows it could be fun we're
going to take a force right there
coming up though um after the break
following the 3-2 diet what office
workers apparently want
as we come out of covid more on that in
a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview and uh with me tonight are the
journalists and author ella whelan and
the author and historian at oxford
university
peter francapan so welcome back to both
of you uh peter we're gonna
kick off this section and with the
double page spread
inside the sunday times and this is
focusing on
what has been an incredibly
disappointing turn of events for dina
asher smith
well dina was carrying the hopes of the
country and i think there are many who
are expecting her to come home
in potentially with two or even three
gold medals in the 100 200 and the relay
and the amount of pressure that she was
under beforehand
um she dealt with having having not
performed as as we'd all hoped in the
semi-final today
incredibly brave and dignified she came
straight back out
and announced that she'd torn a
hamstring um five weeks ago and had kept
that quiet and said
you know look at this level tiny
fractions make tiny differences
and you know i'm going to pull out of
the 200. and and i think the way that
she confronted it head-on
how she spoke about um you know the this
is just how life is it had been any
other point in the last five years apart
from
these last five weeks you know she'd
have been a proper medal contender and
perhaps even for gold
uh heartbreaking but the bravery just
shows what goes into
uh all those early mornings all those
late nights all those ice baths all the
amount of training that goes into these
olympics and the human stories i think
dina has given such a credit i think to
what proper athletics is all about it's
not about winning medals you know as she
said there'll be plenty of other
competitions that she'll win in the
future
and i think that she'll be carrying the
wins of the entire nation behind her
when that happened so desperately
sad for her personally but my gosh the
way that she dealt with it was
incredibly impressive absolutely and so
heartbreaking for her often as you say
you know years of training and then just
the timing is appalling isn't it we send
our sympathies to her
um and finally let's and just like take
a quick look at a very different story
this is
inside the sunday times they're talking
about the three two die but it's a
diff they're not talking about food are
they no no
this is the the work life um balance and
based on
a couple of bits of research one quite
interesting one from yougov which showed
that only a fifth of bosses
um say they'll require all staff to come
in for five days a week this is
mentioned in the article
and there is a suggestion that the new
normal could be three days
in the office and two days at home or
some variation on that
and you know lots of people will be
readdressing their work-life balance and
their work inhabits throughout this
period of strangeness i want to really
make a plea
for going back into um places of work
for
re-delineating between the public and
private sphere not because i think
offices are fantastic places to be or
factories or anywhere else where that's
outside of the home it's quite nice to
sit and pet the cat make yourself a cup
of tea while you're working
but think about what happens to our town
centers our cities our
and you know our public spaces if we
aren't there i think one of the most
dystopian parts of the last 16 months
has been going into
central london i don't know if you guys
have done it i'm walking across
millennium bridge with no one there and
you know and then people wonder why all
the prep workers are getting left left
you know let off
we need a public square to be filled
with the public and that can't happen if
we work from home
sorry to cut you off we are out of time
but we can revisit this in the next hour
ella and peter thanks very much indeed
for now